esto es puerto resistencia una de las
comunidades autónomas de cali nacidas
del paro nacional
allí estado del campo del pueblo nasa y
guardia indígena participa en la mina de
5000 personas una forma de llevar la
canción interna de los territorios al
exterior no venimos así como nos han
dicho que la guardia indígena venía a
violentar al pueblo caleño y desmentir
nosotros venimos a acompañar a hacer la
fuerza al ser la fuerza del pueblo los
guardias indígenas son la principal
defensa que tienen las comunidades al
territorio del campo sólo lleva un
machete y un bastón con eso y la palabra
se enfrenta a paramilitares guerrilleros
narcotraficantes y ejército un cargo de
riesgo que heredó de su padre y que ya
ha transmitido a uno de sus hijos la
lucha que quiero construir para ellos
es un dolor que siento pero la misma
rabia me hace fuerte porque es arrolla
nos debe permitir que nuestros hijos
tengan la tranquilidad esta nación
también es un compromiso y un motivo de
orgullo
los guardias indígenas son respetados en
la comunidad a mí me tocó la primera vez
con mi papá salir si a mi hijo cuides
hay que que hay que dárselo digo como
éste tienen que estar aquí atento a lo
que va a pasar en la primera arremetida
que yo viví en una movilización de
cialis aquí comienza a escribir mi
historia de resistencia tuve el campo no
tiene miedo a la muerte para los
indígenas el mensaje y el legado
continúa más allá de su vida una
convicción de paz y comunidad que están
instaurando en las protestas en cali
aquí no hay terrorismo aquí hay es
sabe
[Aplausos]